hi i'm alex pasek and i clean drains
today we're going to look at a few
drains and i'm going to show you how to
clean them when a drain is clogged the
obvious problem is that it backs up and
water doesn't drain which can cause
flooding which can lead to the drain
backing up further down
its run where it's even harder to to get
a clog out of so regular maintenance of
grains is really important to avoid
those types of things
here we've got a basin drain the water
runs through the grate on the top falls
down into this basin and the water that
falls in brings with it any of the dirt
or sand or whatever else it picks up
with it into that basin so the first
step i do is i pop off the grate top i
see that it's very backed up with the
soil and sand so i start digging just
trying to expose as much of the drain as
i can i see that there's the exit pipe
and around it is a lot of roots uh mixed
in with the sand so i start sort of kind
of break away at those eventually
getting down and pulling out the roots
from the pipe i get further down into
the basin and finally hit the bottom
where the roots are all coiled and i'm
able to pull out those roots all in a
few big pieces and then i
give the drain a quick
scrape out and clean and then pop the
lid back on and that's good to go
so french trains are typically at the
bottom of a sloped driveway and the
reason for that is if a driveway is on a
slope and the house is at the end of the
slope water will continue on the slope
and end up in the house so the french
drains are put there as a way to divert
the water away from the house first i'm
just gonna take off the top i already
can see that there's quite a lot of
debris in here so the first thing i'm to
do is just get my shovel and start
digging it out there's all types of
different creatures living in here some
worms some bags the debris is made up
mostly of soil and sand and pine needles
so
everything that's good for blocking the
drain is in there
then i'm going to start cleaning the
pipe that that exits this drain and
obviously this is important because no
matter how clean the drain is we're
relying on that pipe to bring out the
water
and i don't stop doing that until either
i can sort of see light through the end
of that pipe or until like i'm pretty
certain by shoving something in there
that it is now cleaned out and then i
get out the pressure washer
give the whole chamber and the top of it
a clean which just allows for better
flow and a nicer appearance as well
after that i pop the grates back on and
we're looking at a clean french drain
it's important to keep an eye on the
level of debris in french drains um they
can fill up quite quickly even in the
dryer months it's easy just to look in
and see okay there's a little bit of
stuff in here i can no longer see the
complete face of the
drain it's probably time to open it up
and just see how deep this is and give
it a quick scoop out
these chambers are fairly simple to
clean and it's quite easy just to get a
shovel and start scooping that debris
out this drain didn't have any roots
growing into it which is a good sign
that means that
this debris hasn't probably been there
too too long
a couple years maybe once all of that
muck is scooped out of there i
took the opportunity while it was all
open and and free of debris to actually
give it a good clean so
i got a pressure washer there and was
able just to
clean off the sides of the drain and
that just allows for better flow through
the whole drain as the water
often comes in at the side not actually
right through the top so the smoother of
a surface for the water to go in just
allows a better
all-over flow for the drain
i would say um
you know don't be afraid to to open your
drains and take a look in there it's not
so scary it's probably nothing you can
break in there um really they are quite
simple generally just chambers that fill
up with soil no harm in opening them up
and starting to dig